et si on arrêtait de fumer c'est la
proposition qu'a fait un professeur de
français par ailleurs non fumeurs aux
élèves de l'une de ses classes de
seconde
défi relevé quatre mois après elle les
accros de la cigarette ont presque tous
cessé de fumer grâce notamment à la
solidarité du groupe didier brignan
marina paugam les grandes vacances
approchent et ses élèves de seconde ont
voulu voir leurs professeurs une
dernière fois cette discussion et yann
chloé julia et benjamins ont voulu
qu'elle se déroule dans cette cour
c'était l'ancienne cour fumeurs du lycée
offre
voilà qui est devenu donc voilà un lieu
où maintenant on parle d'art et de
cigarettes
l' aventure a commencé en janvier
dernier patrick loubatière professeur de
français lance un défi à ses élèves
fumeurs à arrêter définitivement la
cigarette la classe se prend au jeu et
relève le challenge
j'avais déjà l'idée en tête de de
réduire mais c'est vrai qu'en fait
réduit finalement on se dit oui de la
semaine et finalement on se rattrape on
enfume 40 le week-end donc bon tout cela
va revient et autant arrêter comme ça
avec les copines ion pour les amis donc
tout d'un verre super motivés donc
visible un jeu près de la falaise
arrêtez donc voilà pas facile de
décrocher alors pour les aider à tenir
leurs professeurs c'est parfois
improvisés psychologue
je leur ai donné mon numéro de téléphone
portable et je leur ai dit vous pouvez
m'appeler à tout moment en toute heure
du jour et de la nuit
même si c'est samedi soir trois heures
du matin en boîte de nuit
si vous êtes entouré de copains qui vous
pousse à fumer et que vous avez besoin
d'elle n'hésitez pas un passe un coup de
téléphone santé si je dors se fera un
plaisir que ceux des fonderies j'ai eu
des appels mais personne ne l'a poussé
le vice un combat mené par tous les
élèves
même les non fumeurs les ont soutenus
demander chaque jour des nouvelles si ça
tenait
si ça allait bien quoi et ça aussi soudé
la place quatre mois après le bilan est
très positif sur les huit élèves accros
à la nicotine
une seule a craqué en cours d'année